[Music]
[Applause]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
your host on Sathyan really excited to
be sitting down with Brittany Neff today
we're gonna be talking about as above so
below we're talking about feminine
intelligence the earth planetary
Alliance we have so much to talk about
really excited to host you pretty thing
thank you so much really so good to be
here yeah and it was such a blessing
that we met transformative technology
conference and we've had your awesome
group of of peeps have entered my life
my cohorts your cohorts I like that yeah
yeah slowly becoming my cohorts really
quickly actually really quickly yeah and
that was that was awesome we did a
really good interview together that
interview will be up soon
we're gonna post produce that and get
that interview up that was on site and
down in Woodside and your Palo Alto
so Brittany as we go into talking about
all of this living systems theory we
have so much to talk about but I want to
know how you get yourself how you find
yourself in this place today
it's been a journey and yeah I think you
know we can start with Co reality and
move from there so reborn was like born
I was born in Culver City California in
Los Angeles and I still call LA home
although the last couple of years I've
been traveling about half the time and
so I'm in and out all around you grow up
there until you're 18 yeah I grew up
there until I was 18 and I now live
across the street from my high school I
you know like this oh gee Tony I've
watched la Santa Monica Venice changed
pretty dramatically yeah but there's a
lot of merging in LA and it's always
calling me back in but yeah I've also
been doing quite a bit of traveling yeah
so when did after 18 how did you how did
you become this person now yeah so after
I went to I went to college in Boston I
went to Tufts University yeah it was a
good it was a really good incubator for
me and such a shift from I mean such a
shift philosophically intellectually
really pushed me intellectually and I
you know I spent a lot of time in Boston
I had a really hard time my freshman
year but and that kind of pushed me out
into the world so I ended up spending
two semesters studying abroad lived in
Buenos Aires lived in Cape Town traveled
all around the world throughout college
learned so much in there like 30
countries there something like yeah I've
been to about maybe 35 countries now
that's crazy yeah yeah so it's been I've
learned so much out in the world and
Tufts Tufts was a great place to to
start that journey my senior year I did
a really intensive year-long colloquium
on global health and security and that
was that was like academic boot camp you
know staying up all night pulling
all-nighters multiple times a week and
just super in that space and did a did a
research project with four of my dearest
the dearest women in my life in India
for about a month and a half my senior
year but after college I was really
burnt out and I felt like something was
missing and I'd been identifying with my
intellect for so long I just I needed to
be I wanted to be with the earth and so
my partner and I moved to Hawaii for
three four months and spent less than a
thousand dollars and had the most dense
rich life experiences living in
communities so he lived in four
different communities that were
dramatically different and I really got
you know got an int
how what what works for people when
they're living in community what works
what doesn't work and it was a beautiful
experience to be able to compare these
different these different communities
big difference living in community
versus living in isolated like apartment
or yes yeah yeah and you know I'm I am
living currently have been living in a
one-bedroom apartment in LA with Ben was
my partner and that's shifting pretty
majorly right now and I I want to be
living in community again because those
that's those are my values and some I'm
ready 2019 I'm gonna be going on going
on tour spending a lot of time visiting
projects and communities that I've
really like piques my interest for many
years I'm gearing up to to do that so
many people are now wanting to move into
shared housing with totally yeah just
having a bedroom inside of a house yeah
with a bunch of other people that you
really like yes we learned so much from
one another you know and I we're all
reflect we're reflecting one another and
it's such a important time to there's a
sense of urgency right now for me where
I'm like I need to be accelerating my
learning and my growth and right now
sometimes we do that on our own if we're
sitting of a pasta or we need to just be
within our own energy and go inward it's
so good
and it's you know it's it's both it's a
both/and yeah but I
yeah yeah yeah I don't think we do
enough of the first one of those two
though I think we do more I don't know
maybe maybe I'm biased because I spend
so much time in the social ether but I I
see - I see over socialization occurring
of civilization and I don't see enough
inward peace occurring and so a lot of
people are fearful of passing time alone
by themselves because they're so used to
socialization you don't know how to even
handle themselves by themselves and
there's a lot of very interesting
self-actualization self-discovery that
can actually occur when we do that and
furthermore even the creativity that can
get rocked forth and brought into the
world now and I'll touch on that just
for a moment because I'm really like
that's been my experience and you know I
stopped the pasta for the first time in
January and it had been in my orbit for
many years and I had so much fear around
it I was terrified to sit and yeah my
mind was playing tricks on me leading
into it that I was gonna I was asking
myself if I could you know die from
boredom like if I was gonna go crazy
being in that that kind of silence and
it was such a beautiful experience to
just be with myself
and yeah I was it was so beautiful and
yeah we all need a lot more solo time
yes I'm seeking that this year as well
go to the deepest roots of human
suffering the suffering and misery and
going and eradicate them get that get
that take back control of your monkey
mind yes
so Brittany what happened after Hawaii
after you discovered the community life
and oh my gosh so many things I bounced
around a lot I won't I won't go into all
of it but lots of traveling you yeah and
I've worked across all different sectors
doing yeah many many things lived in
Oregon for a little while lived in
Guatemala for about four or five months
bounced around a bit and so and I was
really going down more of a health and
wellness path wanting to potentially go
into nursing or I was trying to figure
it out you know I was really attracted
to different modalities of healing more
alternative modalities of healing I was
doing medical translation doing
different things and then my partner Ben
had been working in virtual reality and
I had such an aversion to VR and really
didn't have any interest in it and then
he received a grant through the VR for
good program run by oculus to make a
film make a film for a non-profit and so
he was actually partnered with a Women's
Resource Center in New York called
womankind and I it was just spirit
moving through like I was basically told
that I needed to that I was to be
involved in that project so I pivoted
and pretty majorly
and ended up rise above rise above yeah
and so that was about two year two years
ago now we shot that in New York and I
had no idea what I was I you know no
idea what I was doing but I was just
following the call that I was to you
know was to help with this project and
it was such a such a transformative
experience we made the film with us or a
young survivor of sexual assault named
Brittany who became like a dear friend
and yeah I was it was really powerful to
work with her and so we had a really
small team and it was pretty running gun
but a beautiful experience and that
really catalyzed for me that I catalyzed
that I wanted to be involved with
helping people tell their stories and
have transformational experiences and so
you actually made this in with a 360
camera yeah so we're super we made this
with the Nokia ozo and you click and
drag around the YouTube video yeah you
can drag around and ideally watching a
head set but yeah yeah so and so she got
over yes it's it was we were really like
how are we going to make a 360 film
about the subject matter that is like
aesthetically pleasing and
and and also not like re-enacting trauma
and so it really became about her
reclaiming autonomy over her story and
reflecting on her healing journey and so
it was and it became such a big part of
her healing process and it was such a it
was such a gift to be a part of that
yeah so that really that really sent me
on my way and then Ben and I kept on
creating content together and really all
sorts of things in VR and and then I
really you know I hope this ended up
unleashing the the potential for other
people to be able to talk about their
story and their integration yeah I mean
it was very timely it was before kind of
me to movement but yeah I think it I
think it did catalyze a lot and there's
such an uprising now in society of women
feeling like they're you know feeling
like they can come and tell their
stories and it was such a you know I've
had my own experiences with sexual
trauma and an assault and so that I that
I neglected for a long time and in
making being a part of helping her share
her voice really really unlocked a lot
for me and my my own healing so it was
incredible and and then moving from
there I I really also want to see that
you here this is only one of many
productions that was made I mean rise
above retrospective and this and I have
to say we have not updated this website
in a long time very busy but the cool
thing is that your work here is across
many different experiences and you're
capturing it in virtual reality it's
very it's more it's a new more of a
newer age capture method as well it's
not just totally a normal
two-dimensional
here you're taking people into a
three-dimensional into a they're able to
go through that if you're in a 360 cam
also you're able to go through and click
through a few VR you're able to actually
immerse yourself in it so again this is
this is very cool that you ended up
making a yeah this is the studio in this
and now and now we're gonna also talk
about what where it's going from here
but continue continual yeah and so I'd
kind of just to kind of get into the
meat of the conversation I so weird that
we say meat yeah I'm vegan so I actually
observed myself like saying that in that
moment and bizarre what how bizarre it
is since birds yeah let's get into the
substance of the conversation anything
let's just not use meat again
but yeah so so it was really you know
2017 was a very transforming
transformational year and summer of 2017
I was starting to really get into
environmental justice work and really
wanting to share narratives that would
shift consciousness around environmental
issues and our relationship to the
natural world and and so I don't even
really know how it all ended up
happening but it was definitely
synchronous and spirit weaving its way
through us we were kind of at the whim
of what was just snowballing and so we
ended up going down to Brazil and making
a VR 360 documentary about the in
maranhão and Brazil which is in the
northeastern part of the Amazon and we
made a film about what Sonia guada who
is an incredible indigenous leader
she just ran she was just on the
unfortunately she didn't win but she was
just running for vice president of
Brazil she was the first eco eco
feminist indigenous leader to ever run
for public office at that level
and so hopefully many more many more
many more definitely and she's she's
such a strong leader and hero of mine
and we we ended up making this film with
her in her village with the guada forest
protectors guardians of the forest and
so they're you know the many tribes in
the Amazon and all of all over Latin
America and all across the world in
different tropical forest regions are
self-organizing to monitor their land
from illegal logging and so we went in
to their territory and went out to
actually find illegal loggers and went
on a raid with about 30 men Wow and we
captured the nitrate of them finding and
apprehending illegal loggers and then
actually setting the trucks on fire
because they wanted to they want to
destroy the equipment and so there were
these you know 500 year old trees major
trees that had already been cut down and
we're in these trucks and they just they
lit it all on fire and it's not leaving
the truck itself its crew ting the truck
itself we drove out into the we drove
out into the darkness watching it kind
of all in explode behind us it was
pretty wild thing I saw that it's not
actually on here right now I saw the
wood did you have a photo of it no you
didn't have a photo of it I think
someone may be some somehow I saw I
don't know if it was I'm one of your
social piece you might have saw a social
page we ended up so that was a wild
experience we were in Brazil for five
weeks to determine no I mean and they're
not the enemy you know what happens is
there's so few like protections on the
land that the and people are in such
deep poverty like they're trying to do
whatever they can do to get by and these
mafias are just cropping up and they're
you know they're paying nothing they're
hiring
they're like hired guns basically but
for so little so little money and
they're going in and they just they
clear out these big trees and
yeah and get paid nothing to do it it's
really really brutal and I it was such
an eye-opening experience to be down
there and really I mean to go to
maranhão which is in the I mean really
on the frontlines of environmental
destruction it's not like we went into
the beautiful Amazon Amazon we went for
station maranhão which is has been
almost completely deforested and the
only the only pockets of forest left our
indigenous territory but they're they're
desperately trying to protect and so
yeah and and just driving through the
Amazon they're they're you know they're
just they go people they go in they
clear out all the big trees that are
worth anything and then they just burn
the rest of the forest and all over
Brazil and in South America there
they're doing this to clear mostly to
clear the land mass mass parts of the
forest to just clear the land to raise
cattle and so we just would drive for
hours yeah and just drive first here's
maranhão mm-hmm and we drive for hours
we spent some time in madaba which is in
paadhai aside next to maranhão and then
we since spent some time in the impetus
and then into the territory into the adi
Boyett territory Wow
yeah it was such an eye-opening
experience and to really understand
where we're at and what's happening
around the world in terms of like the
mass genocide of the natural world and
it was hard for me to move through that
and but but it's my souls work too to
bear witness to what's happening and to
bring it to light bring it to light to
bring it to life and yeah and really I
guess like what I kind of want to get
into is what what moved what's been so
like life-changing for me in my in the
way that I understand myself in
relationship to the world
to others is was finding join a Macy's
work and those of you who don't know
joining me see is is 89 or 90 now and
she is an environmental philosopher she
developed a body of work called the work
that reconnects and she's really all
about like helping people come to move
through their pain the pain that they're
feeling for the world and we're all
we're all kind of so connected to our
planet it's our it's our collective
mother and there is you know and she's
under attack she's under attack and
we're we're responsible for that attack
and but until we yeah and until we
really pheromones live allow ourselves
to grieve and feel the pain for the
world we're not going to be able to like
really yeah be able to enact the
scalable solutions that are needed and
so what we need is a philosophical shift
yeah a global philosophical chef-y yeah
how we gonna do that how are we gonna do
that
so can we quick on the way environmental
activist author scholar foodism general
Systems Theory Deep Ecology author of
eight books and like you said work that
reconnects the central purpose of the
work that reconnects is to help people
uncover and experience their innate
connections with each other and with the
systemic self-healing powers of the web
of life so they may be enlivened and
motivated to play their part in creating
sustainable civilization fantastic yeah
so and before going to Brazil I mean I
was doing so much research around
climate change and was deeply depressed
really had no idea how I was gonna go to
Brazil and do this thing and was just in
such a dark place and then I discovered
her work and it and she has her her book
is called coming back to life and it
really brought me back to life and gave
me the tools that I needed to go down to
Brazil and
this do this project and bear witness to
what was happening and go into that
experience with an open heart and so
yeah Ron's inquiry about Ron's inquiry I
think what she brings to light is this
you know she's a deep ecologist and deep
thinker in living systems theory which
is a multidisciplinary approach to
understand that we are living in a leaf
living living breathing interdependent
system that we ourselves in a larger
body and we're remembering our function
our highest function in our collective
body and that has been such a you know
III I've always known that on some level
but she really brings the language to it
that's been so mind expanding for me and
now I'm seeing it everywhere the way the
way that nature self-organizes and is is
moving through us if we let it if we
allow allow for it and it's this it is
this process of surrender and allowing
the you know allowing for the emergence
of nature to move through and we're all
collectively deep in that process right
now yeah so do you have other questions
around her work yeah I answer your
question even just living systems theory
in general is here required to explain
the nature of life that's a pretty good
way to put it
self-organizing life forms interact with
their environment maintained by flows of
information energy and matter so I can
click on live yeah and the Wikipedia
itself yeah yeah I like how some
scientists are now saying that last few
decades is required explain the nature
of life and and I think this really ties
in to like the overview effect and the
ions Institute in the bay is really
centered around the overview effect
which is when astronauts have left have
gone out of the atmosphere and are
looking down at earth
and have this total like samadhi
experience where they realize that the
earth is one thing the earth is alive
and breathing and and yeah the blue mark
and that changes it changes everything
it changes it does ships everything and
everything because we're all living
we're all living in these stories that
we're creating and so much work were
co-creating reality and it's time to
create a better story so we can live in
harmony together yeah and and and Joanna
Macy last thing I'll really say about
her is she she talks about a lot about
story and how we're living in the story
that we're creating and the three most
dominant stories are this business as
usual that things this is the way things
are they're never gonna change this is
the way it is the great unraveling which
is the story that's telling us that our
that our complex living systems are
collapsing unraveling insight these are
these are the scientists that are
telling later like trying to wake us up
to what's happening and then the third
story is the great turning and this is I
just got a little some chill great
turning sounds like what we need to do
and the great turning and we're we're
all living in these three in these three
stories and the great turning is this
those of us who don't want the great
unraveling to have the last word and are
starting to think about how we can scale
these these these ideas and yeah and and
and and our you know what like Charles
Eisenstein says the the world that are
the more beautiful world that our hearts
know is possible like it's right in our
it's right in our and arms reach and we
just have to continue to choose it
moment to moment and continue to show up
and and love one another
[Music]
so it's like three trajectories it's
negative neutral and positive seems to
be a okay way to put it yeah you can
maybe put it like that I think it's yeah
I think it's helpful to just think of
them as these people are living in these
stories and so what are you gonna how
are you gonna integrate those three and
like with Julia yesterday we were
talking we're touching on them and she
was saying like she has a hard time with
really living in the business-as-usual
story but it's important that we build
bridges between the three so we're not
living in this illusion that of you know
that everything is fine because it's not
you know and and we have to kind of come
to terms with all of it and integrate it
seven and a half billion humans to try
and mm-hmm
convinced move in a positive direction
totally but things like this help this
is part one of the experiences that you
guys are exploring playing with yeah
overview effect taking people off of
Earth and into looking down at it and
then into an experience it's all very
exciting we think a lot in the same way
with creating experiences in that sense
totally that's a good one there's a
couple other points maybe as we round
out this and then go into into the next
section do should we should we mention
just I mean you've already been talking
about this I mean I think the embodiment
piece yeah just you know these
philosophies that's been the shift for
me even like now that I've found the
language the language is the gateway to
them the embodiment for me in terms of a
lot of the this philosophy that I've
been reading and beginning to have this
now experiential understanding this
embodiment of our interconnectedness and
to have the opportunity to choose that
for a moment a moment and to choose love
and should show up yeah
and so that's been that's kind of been
my trajectory so that's one point that I
guess we wanted to explore yeah choose
love mm-hmm and choose to believe in
just to believe in our
interconnectedness you know all all
signs are you know all science is
backing this up all all disciplines are
showing us quantum quantum physics
everything is pointing to our ru unified
consciousness that all we are is
vibration and frequency and we're we're
you know we're co-creating this
experience together
yeah yeah I like the resonance theory of
consciousness that was very interesting
that we vibe on a higher frequency that
that can lead to more love and more
coherence between people and then just
that there's oh maybe a different sort
of residence for something that is a
plant or an animal just just different
resonance yeah it can be a little
difficult to actually talk to the seven
and a half billion people about it can
people about it things just being
vibration and total hating so I think a
lot of you know I think science and
mysticism are being bridged right now
and there will be a there will be more
of a the more relatable and
understanding can be definitely in this
in this direction the easier it'll be to
talk to people about it in the TTC
conference the trans transformational
technologies conference where we met was
so enlightening for me because I yeah I
don't I'm not super technical but some
of yeah some of the technologies that
are being created with that from that
heart space with that intention that are
scalable can have a massive I mean a
mass
impact the heart math project really
blew me away and ya won't get into that
but yeah definitely look into it because
it'sit's pretty revolutionary what
they're doing yeah yeah yeah hard math
in general is extremely interesting
there's like the heart math Institute to
experience science-based technology
programs for taking charge of your life
reduce stress and anxiety by increasing
your inner heart math mm-hmm
and Christian your inner balance of self
security learn to access your hearts
intuition to become
the-best-version-of-yourself more often
so this is all I mean this is a lot of
what is being explored right now by your
team by transformative technology by
several of the people that we've had on
the show and yeah it's becoming a
reoccurring theme so okay wander us into
how things moved into the feminine
intelligence and new earth planetary
Alliance yeah what are those things yeah
I know where does collective reality fit
into okay yeah I'll lay it out okay as
best I can but it is very it's also very
emergent them and it's you know it's
only been a couple months that things
that have really started to
self-organize but yeah so about two
months ago I met amber Gibson who you
interviewed on the show and she's
bringing through some very potent
powerful codes and they resonated with
me deeply and so we have a very potent
connection and when she was first
telling me what she was doing I really
didn't believe it because it was so
massive I mean the way that she's
thinking on such a systems level and
then she started showing me what she's
doing and you know much of it some of it
I used to you know I have such as I have
a soft understanding of it but I really
am I'm a weaver and I understand how all
the pieces are coming to fit together
and so you know I wanted to be involved
she wanted me to get involved and we
started self-organizing and different
kind of people came in with all carrying
different pieces that are so important
and everyone's coming from this embodied
place of this embodied understanding of
our interconnectedness and from a heart
space and so that's been really
incredible to be a part of this emergent
collective where we're showing up and
we're doing the work and where we're
stewarding coherence within our
collective and
figuring out where all the puzzle pieces
fit and so and Kara Drake who is was
what you didn't meet her but she's the
the initial founder of feminine
intelligence and what came through her
that like the impetus for creating this
feminine intelligence which is many
things but an accelerator was the this
Vanity Fair article that said like the
15 most influential minds and the
creation of artificial intelligence
we're all men and you know there's so
much fear around what's being created in
AI and you know she felt like she really
wanted to bring these feminine values
into the creation of not just AI but all
you know all sorts of emergent
technologies and so to really anchor in
with that intention is incredibly
important that's that's really why I
first got involved with VR at the
forefront I didn't even really know it
then and I continued to find myself in
these these these texts these tech
spaces and I have kind of a subversion
on one hand and then the other hand I
know I'm exactly where I need to be and
I need to share my voice in this
conversations so that where as where as
we're accelerating and creating
everything is coming from this like
rooted space yeah intentional space yeah
and so Kara is the the fi is now being
kind of expanded and all of our
collective is part of the fi council
that feminine intelligence council and
we have a lot of visions and dreams for
what we're going to co-create together
and each of us are bringing these
different pieces so Ben and I have
brought brought through Co reality which
collective reality which from the
beginning we imagined it was like our
passion project of you know an outward
representation of our of our
philosophical in our philosophical
evolution and we wanted it to be we
always imagined it to be like a
collective you know part of a collective
but it's really just been him and I and
his
like doing some different projects over
the last couple of years and the last
year we've really put it aside and I was
working I've been working for an
incredible environmental nonprofit
called if not us then who this year
working more directly with supporting
indigenous communities in the tropical
forest regions and Ben's been doing
other work as well so now it's kind of
we're coming back around or form this
this collective is self-organizing and
we're we're give we're giving Co reality
over to the collective so it can be our
platform to share content ideas
everything that's coming out of the
accelerator it can be this the landing
place for people to come together and
experience what we're creating and get
involved so that yeah so that's how it's
kind of all self-organizing and then
there's different piece pieces so
Christopher pitcher who's the founder of
impact labs we've worked with them on
and after last year we saw our impact
labs and collective reality are they
being baked into FI yes they're being
baked into baked into new earth
planetary alliance yes it's a it's a
it's a decentralized ecosystem so we can
continue to decentralize nodes that are
all collaborating and working together
definitely notice planetary Alliance is
handling a lot of the protocols and
frameworks
yeah these communities are collaborate
across the world totally then fi is an
accelerator for feminine intelligence
ideas and projects into the world even
an impact and it's a lot of moving
closer they are kind of making the media
around these yes narratives and they're
all decentralized other people can join
in and make the ideas and go under these
brands and yeah and work in these hubs
an impact labs has really been you know
I think their business model right now
is they've really been there working
with brands they're working with the
private sector to like infuse the doing
branding and marketing consulting and
doing a I mean their work really runs
the gamut but they're they're doing
really heart-centered work and bringing
a lot of different players into the
ecosystem so they can continue to
to work independently but then they're
also baked into this growing ecosystem
yep yeah so what's going on with the
future of the ecosystem let's we'll wrap
on this like yeah what's going on with
the future of the ecosystem mm-hmm
yeah I mean we're working we're
continuing to meet we're continuing to
develop protocols were you know we're
we're calling in visit a physical lab
cowork Co live space in LA to begin with
where we can start really like
incubating these these ideas the
majority of our team is in LA and so but
people are all over the world we have a
you know didn't Greg Cassell who's one
of the top thinkers and peer-to-peer
protocols he's developing the protocols
he's in Atlanta and Kayla Yang is in one
of the founders of the global eco
village network and he's up in Portland
and then Dimitri is in Russia and he's
developing a cognitive assistant and so
there there are all these different
nodes and we're really in this
exploratory phase of what wants to
emerge but everyone's coming from this
deep resonant heart space and it's we're
just very mission aligned and what we're
trying to bring into the world and so
yeah not to overuse the word emergence
but it is a very emergent process that's
really only been a couple of months that
it's been coupled together so we're
right on that we're right on the
forefront but I think each one of us is
bringing a wealth of experience and
insights from the last few years and now
it's all kind of coming it's coming
together so we're I think you know we've
been talking about like we're modeling
we're modeling new new ways of
interrelating or emergent ways of
interpreting yeah so that people can see
people can continue that that has a
resonance that has a vibration that that
ripples out it's it's like a fractal the
fractal nature of the universe yeah
as above so good as above so below and
this is this is a very interesting I
think you know on the on the way I
really like this that which is below
corresponds to that which is above and I
was above course possible well touch the
mirror those are the one thing so
there's a you know Ron can pull this one
up but if you you know if you take a
look over here at our little at our
little our little flag no roundabout
over to it this is a this is a good way
to explain the you know the as above so
below right there with the root systems
and the tree leaves and this is so much
good right there what happens on one
level of reality also happens on every
other level the microcosm and the
macrocosm behave alike mm-hmm yeah
really beautifully sad and that's really
like the heart of what we're creating is
this this embodied understanding of it's
all the same body understanding of
living systems theory as above so below
but the inner is the outer you know and
and and that we are we ourselves in a
larger body yeah and so all of the
protocols that we're developing we're
calling them biomimetic protocols that
they're they are anchored in our
understanding of of the natural world
and how nature self-organizes yeah these
neologisms are very interesting
biomimetic so cultural thank you wrong
cultural information transfer based on
biology based on natural mm-hmm natural
systems it's very interesting to like
the neologisms will be interesting to
try and disseminate them quickly and get
them to catch on fast and effectively
and that's the thing about language as
well I think it's it's it's everything
feels so accelerated right now a lot of
this language it it has like a it has
the lifespan until it gets overused and
and it kind of died as it loses its
meaning and so we knock our gonna not
love not lie I don't think love I don't
think love lost it I mean if you say it
like that at my resonance coherence
won't die it's a it's a powerful love is
an incredibly powerful transcendent
force in the universe the university's
love it is it is its vibration I mean my
understanding is that it's trying to put
words so the cosmos is so funny like
like nature's love yes and you know when
all else fails I come back to love I
come back to trying to embody love and
show up in that and for a moment to
moment and I make so many mistakes and I
get reactive and I'm you know I'm a
total brat sometimes ask my partner for
six years yeah and what you know and
we're moving into the field of quantum
relationship and what's possible as we
as we explore unconditional love and
acceptance of wherever the other the
other is and what's in flow for us so
that's us stay in your corner really
modeling modeling what's possible in
relationally and and how we how we show
up and love for one another yeah and
whatever that looks like you know and
that's a nut shifting a lot right now
yeah like the term planetary architect
mm-hmm like that term like the
civilizational design term yeah I like
thinking about the protocols and
frameworks that are going to enable the
maximal resource flow between people for
self and collective actualization I
think we're absolutely on our way there
I really enjoy featuring people like you
and like
was on the show yesterday and your whole
team was so fun you guys down in
Woodside I have a very lot of teams that
transformative technology conference
where a lot like you were a lot yeah
from the heart coming from so great
bringing forth this transition to to
civilization and it's really really
exciting and I and I hope the the ones
in power I hope through either
meditation psychedelics through just
practices of ego loss of any sort just
through loving energy coming from people
like us can slowly like release the grip
on the economic and political machinery
that exists today to enable these new
frameworks to come in and if they choose
not to they'll still get overthrown by
all the young people that are coming in
with with Millennials and Gen Z and even
the kids born today they're just gonna
come in and and and build the new
systems regardless of what the old
systems want the course of nature is
moving through us and what I'm what's
beautiful what's been coming up for me a
lot the last few days um it's just the
environmental Cataclysm underway that's
ramping up its very accelerated I mean
California is on fire you know
California is completely on fire and
across the world we're experiencing you
know rapid environmental environmental
disasters just one after the other and
we're talking about being able to feel
it's not was it wasn't eco eco paralysis
eco anxiety there's these words for for
feeling the fires and for feeling the
certification of the oceans and for and
for feeling the parts per million of co2
been increasing and it wakes us up it's
a wake-up call yeah it's part of the
path of a weakening it is part of the
powerful and we don't even have to do
anything the earth will do it the earth
is doing it but we can continue to share
and spread this consciousness and love
our mother love one another
and while tenders see wild tenders and
good stewards and start really what I
was coming up for me to start really
living our values like I no longer I
have this consciousness I need to I need
to fully embody and practice what I'm
preaching and so I'm I'm I'm committed
to taking steps in my own life to get
closer and closer to that full
embodiment and practice yeah Wow
Brittany Neff what a pleasure I want to
ask you one question we typically ask to
the end of the show okay what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
Oh oh my gosh the most beautiful thing
in the world
mmm well I won't get too deep into this
but what's coming up for me in this
moment is the butterfly is has been such
a teacher for me and Darwin said that
evolution is written on the wings of
butterflies and so I've really I've
really gone deep into a butterfly hole
to understand the ways in which our of
our human evolution is modeling the way
in which a caterpillar goes into the
chrysalis becomes this primordial soup
and the imaginal cells begin to
proliferate and the butterfly emerges as
a as a new organism mmm from the
caterpillar from the caterpillar so
that's why you pick the butterfly
because it it does the transition does
the transition it's gorgeous and then it
can fly yes and that's cool and a couple
an evolutionary process one of the cool
dads yes and I love the the the cells
that begin to just like appear and
proliferate and turn the caterpillar
into this new new emergent organism is
called the imaginal saw it's beautiful
imaginal seminal cell mm-hmm and and
butterflies butterflies it takes
multiple generations of the butterfly to
you finish there their migration pattern
so the journey is literally encoded in
their DNA the same the same butterflied
that begins the mic the same monarch
butterfly that begins the migration in
Mexico is not the same generation that
that finishes the migration and so
that's I think I've just very poetic and
beautiful that we know we continue to
show up and the journey is encoded in us
and we're gonna we're going to carry the
baton for the next generation and and
you know keep it's keep it going and
yeah so I think that's that's been a
really maybe the most beautiful thing in
the world there's so many beautiful
beautiful things in the world but that's
a really good one I like that one a lot
yeah
evolution and I'm going I'm going down
to Michoacan in Mexico at the end of
January
anyone feels called to come you're
invited down to down at the end of
January to see the Monarchs in in Mexico
where they begin their migration and so
they're there for January in February
and it's been a dream of mine to go and
see them so caterpillar stops eating
hangs upside down from a twig or leaf
and spins itself a silky cocoon or bolts
into a shiny chrysalis within its
protective casing capra radically
transformed his body you eventually
emerging as a butterfly or moth mm-hmm
yeah
I mean there's so many amazing tie-ins
like philosophical tie-ins into the
butterfly so Paul come on in come on in
man what's up what's up Paul shooting
another video with us later today we're
we're almost we're almost done with the
show we're about to close out this is
good this is good this was a great
answer I love this answer great and I
love sharing that answer it's really
good on that's a really really powerful
yeah for me many others yeah again I'm
really deeply in love with what the
vibes the resonance that's coming from
you and coming from your your coat would
you calm your cohorts I love that your
cohorts yeah you're very very beautiful
group and very beautiful mission of
planetary architecture a lot of other
powerful people working on this let's
bring them together mm-hmm
let's bring them together and let's
usher in the next the next era of civil
Golden Age the Golden Age let's do it
we have the right tools we have the
right hearts we have the right we do the
right transition
so we're thinking about civilization
from thousands and tens of thousands and
hundreds of thousands of years ago until
now every time spin this like Golden Age
Golden Age of an age and now we're here
where we can birth out at the womb and
we can have the right the right
infrastructure and resource flows to
really actualize everybody it's very
yeah it's very interesting is this the
actual Golden Age how many times well
and what do we choose what are we gonna
choose to create you know like Joseph
Campbell's work has also been really
powerful for me in understanding like
the world is myth and that we're
creating these stories and what we've
been talking about a lot is these these
mythologies around Atlantis which was
you know ancient civilization very
technological civilization would say
more in the masculine and then the
Lemurian civilization which the
mythology around the Lemurians are that
they were like very spiritually evolved
and varying their feminine and so we've
been talking about both of those a lot
and kind of coming in like the
integration of those that consciousness
that was woven through each of those
civilizations yeah and that's been fun
to play with you know like what what
yeah what are what story we're choosing
what are we going to co-create and how
are we going to show up so and holding
on to that the genealogy of of knowledge
over time so there we go this has been a
great show boom Britney thank you very
much coming on the show
thank you no you are amazing thank you
for joining us of course is my pleasure
okay yeah yes thank you for thank you
for holding the space for so many and
getting out these ideas in this
consciousness it's really big big big
important work and I'm really grateful
that you're doing it couldn't do without
epic yes
thank you yeah thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you yeah
thanks to our beautiful studio that we
have here in downtown San Francisco
thank you to you guys for viewing and
making this possible as well give us
your thoughts in the comments below we'd
love to hear from you also do join us in
the movement go build your destiny into
the world going manifest your dreams
everyone also join us so that we can
continue sustaining this and building it
so if you join us we got patreon
cryptocurrency links below find Brittany
online find the collective reality down
blinkx below and the bio much love
everyone we will see you soon
much love we love you love ya
[Music]